Вони зустрілися, поснідали,
поговорили та розійшлися.
"Український сніданок" Меркель, Макрона та Путіна -
одна із двох ключових зустрічей в межах саміту Великої двадцятки,
на якій обговорювали Україну.
Її результат - домовленість про необхідність втілити Мінські угоди,
передусім в частині припинення вогню.
Після зустрічі - жодних офіційних коментарів політиків.
Лише французький президент Макрон між іншим заявив,
що розмова була хороша,
але це процес в розвитку.
Другою зустріччю, на якій Україна була топ-темою,
стали понад двогодинні перемови Трампа та Путіна напередодні.
США та Росія домовилися налагодити свій канал зв’язку
щодо конфлікту в Україні.
Це не є альтернативою Нормандському формату
та в ході цих консультацій не розроблятимуть паралельних
до Мінська домовленостей. Це швидше побічне
залучення США до врегулювання кризи в Україні.
В ході саміту Великої двадцятки помітним стало те,
що Путін, немовби-то, повернувся до "великої політичної родини".
Якщо одразу після конфлікту в Україні його сприймали як політичного вигнанця,
то на саміті Джі20 - дещо інакше.
Не в останню чергу, завдяки заяві Трампа
про те, що для нього велика честь
зустрітися з Путіним.
Меркель натомість продемонструвала дипломатичну дистанцію
і до Путіна, і до Трампа.
Їм вона лише потисла руки, вітаючи на полях саміту.
Натомість свого європейського партнера Макрона
пані канцлерка поцілувала,
так само як і голову Єврокомісії Жан-Клода Юнкера.